the Joe Rogan experience when did things
get weird when did you realize they at
what point in time did you say hey this
is not normal work like this doesn't
even seem like it's from this planet
that I can't tell you what day that
occurred on because so much time has
gone by the days of kind of fuse into
one and I can whisper today's was it a
slow burn or was there a moment of
recognition well there the the first
inkling I had was when I I came in
normal there's this facility that is at
s4 it's in the side of a mountain and
normally we had pulled in with the bus
and gone around the front through a
normal double door this time that I went
in there were hangar doors open I went
into the hangar door and in the hangar
door was the disc the flying saucer that
I worked on I saw it sitting there and
we walked by a headed little American
flag stuck on the side and I thought oh
my god this finally explains all the
flying saucer stories this is just an
advanced fighter and it this is [ __ ]
hilarious right so I went by ice lose my
hand alongside it I got reprimanded
immediately for touching the thing and
there was a guy in armed guard that
followed us in and just said keep your
eyes at forward in your hands at your
side and just walk in the door so that
was the first time I had seen anything
that was weird
it was sometime later that I was
introduced to my my lab partner Barry
and we had some of the subcomponents of
the craft in the lab and Barry was very
anxious to get a new lab partner so he
was very talkative and couldn't wait to
show me different things and it was in
the demonstration of the reactor working
where it caught my attention to where
this is technology that doesn't even
exist so I mean that was the first time
I knew that this is really something
different what was it what was it what
was a what was it about this
reactor that made you think that it
didn't exist technologically well it was
that I actually have to back up because
there were some briefings that I read it
before that that you know certainly gave
me the impression that this is going to
be a weird job but this was the first
hands-on thing this was a small reactor
about the size of a hemisphere about the
size of a basketball on a metal plate
and when it was running it produced a
gravitational field a gravitational
field of its own now this is something
that we can't do we can't produce any
gravity the only way we get gravity is
from large quantities of mass but
there's no machine we can have that
turns on that makes gravity like you
know you can turn on an electromagnet
and it makes a magnetic field we can't
make a gravitational field
anyway this device was producing that
and Barry said it's almost like he was
bragging go ahead try and try and touch
the sphere and I I couldn't it would it
pushed my hands away just like two light
poles of a magnet so that was so when
you take two magnets and try to press
them together yeah yeah kind of cushion
feeling but you can't you can't get them
together the closer you put them the
more they push but you felt that
physical with my hand yeah now there's
nothing there's nothing that does that
and that immediately caught my attention
going wow this is something else what
was your thought like when you felt that
and you knew that there was nothing that
you were aware of that could prevent ice
that connected me to the briefings that
I read on the the first day at s4 was
that you know everything that I had read
was apparently accurate what were you
reading I read it was kind of an
overview this project was to back
engineer the alien craft and
specifically it was to try and back
engineer and see if we can duplicate the
technology with available materials now
to do this they split the project into
you know many different pieces for
several reasons they do this on all
classified project so nobody has the
complete story but they compartmentalize
everything now we had the power and
propulsion
system so what briefings they gave me
were like a one or two page overview of
some of the other projects that were
going on you know on the craft the only
reason they do that is just in case what
you're working on is connected
intimately in some way that we don't
know of - one of the other projects you
have to know there excuse me their
existence so you know I bet again I have
everything from metallurgy - you know
weapon potential the craft and these
were all you know essentially very short
briefings but mine was just power and
propulsion and it made it very clear
that what I read was accurate so when
you're reading that before you actually
saw the reactor what were your thoughts
on what they were describing if you knew
that something like that didn't exist
and they're describing it in the
briefings what did you think you were
gonna see I really I didn't know at the
time I mean I was reading I thought is
this is some kind of test
see if you're crazy well not to see if
I'm crazy - you know a lot of times
they'll take in real high-security jobs
I mean they'll intentionally insert
nonsense into him whether it's to
confuse the fact or if for someone was
to leak it out they would carry that
information along and know where it came
from so I read through the documents but
you know I didn't know if this was you
know part of some kind of test or you
know or what or was it potentially
realistic I mean I'd really didn't
consider it being all that possible as
far as being the actual thing that I was
going to work on at the time how did
they turn it on there the reactor yeah
you reacted can be turned on or turned
off in a lot of different ways the way
Barry showed me it the hemisphere is
removed there's a small Tower in the
middle when you put the hemisphere on
the reactor activates the reactor shuts
down it's it's load sensing so if
there's if there's no load on the
reactor at all it shuts down when
there's a load present on it
it starts up again load meaning you can
consider it an electrical load so
although it doesn't necessarily operate
electrically there's no wiring that
connects any of the sub components
together whatsoever they just have to be
in the immediate vicinity it's a it is
but the stuff is borderline magic and
that's essentially where we left it you
know when I left the project so there
was no progress made there was some
progress I mean we did identify at least
we think some processes and and had a
rough idea we think of what was going on
but I think this is a problem that
they've had for a long time and you know
that I was replacing somebody that Barry
worked with prior to me and I think
there was some horrific accident that I
didn't have a whole lot of information
on but you know Barry alluded to that a
horrific accident like were someone died
or yeah where somebody died because they
were trying to tamper with things or
figure out how something worked yeah the
reactor in particular but yet he let you
touch it yeah I think what they were
trying to do was cut into one now they
had they had more than one there and I
that was supposedly there was an
unannounced nuclear test and that's what
it was at the time remember they would
still do an underground nuclear test at
the test site but from what I understand
according to Barry there was an attempt
made now this must have been a pretty
desperate attempt because it's not a
very scientific process to cut you know
analyze something that way but it looked
like they used a plasma cutter or
something I got to cut into an exactor
how many of these things they have they
had nine nine craft altogether I only
got hands-on with one of them so I can't
really say what the how the others
operated you see the other ones yeah at
one time and only one time the bay doors
that between the hangars were all open
and I could see all the way through and
were they all exactly the same no they
were all different different shapes yeah
but they were all from somewhere else
yeah absolutely
now did anyone make any attempt to
explain or to to tell you where they
came from no no no one is the least bit
interested in letting everybody know all
the facts they want to give you the
minimum information that's necessary to
complete your task so you're not getting
the story of where they came from you're
not getting a story of what how much
progress other people are making you
just focus on the small component but
they gave you some indication that
they've been working on these for a
while yeah when do you think they
acquired these I really couldn't say I
think they've been around for a while so
they bring you into this room you see
this reactor working you you realize
this is nothing that as far as like the
scientific community at current time has
the ability to create wait you still
don't what is your life like from that
moment on is that where everything
changes because you do I mean I would
imagine the moment you actually make
contact with something that's
extraterrestrial whether it's an object
or a being something where you can
actually absolutely be certain it's not
from here your whole paradigm the whole
world you live in is now a different
place well this is the only time it
became exciting you know the rest of the
time though it was really an an ominous
feeling being at work but at that time
it was exciting I mean this was now I
knew we were on the absolute beyond
actually beyond the cutting edge of
science and I was I was so absolutely
excited to be there every single time I
was you know what this was a fantastic
opportunity and however in in short
order it began to concern me we really
have no idea what we're talking about
and the excitement kind of turned to
dread at some point because the amount
of power we're dealing with is
astronomical
I mean to affect gravity to produce the
effects
like this equipment does takes huge
amounts of power and I've given the
example before of you know taking a
small portable nuclear reactor and you
know putting it back into Victorian
times you know with the scientists of
the time and just dropping it in a room
and they come and look at it and see
that it's producing power and wonder how
it works so they start taking it apart
and as soon as they get some of the
shielding off the people are gonna drop
dead because of the radiation inside now
the people have no idea that it
radiation even exists back then but
anybody that comes in to check on them
will also drop dead and you know there's
no reason that that exact scenario
couldn't happen with what we're dealing
with we have no idea how the physics
operate within this thing the power
levels are art like I said astronomic
like it's incredibly dangerous to tinker
with something like that and you know in
some respects we were guinea pigs just
try to find out how to make this thing
so they'd had a series as far as you
surmised they had a series of different
scientists try to back engineer this
thing try to figure out what this thing
was and they would bring in new people
and like let's throw Bob at it yeah yeah
and they you know I don't know how many
but I knew there was certainly one
before me and I knew he died during the
analysis of the or the reactor itself
and you don't know how many have worked
on it and no one gave this could have
been there for 50 years it could have
been there for five years when they give
you instructions what are they saying
like when they're giving you Direction
they're showing you all this stuff like
what what what are they saying what
specifically what are they asking of you
well essentially what they ask is is
what I said we are just to gather as
much information as possible find out
how it operates and see if we can
duplicate it so but they notice realize
you where it was from they never let you
ask questions about where it's from well
if the information I read in the
briefings was accurate now what I do
have to say is the information that
pertain directly to the reactor was
accurate what I read
did I mean did jive with reality in
terms of how in terms of how it was made
how what we saw how it operated the
materials how it you know turned on and
what was discovered discovered about it
I'm sorry the migraine is really making
it hard for me to thank you sorry no and
we we talked that before the podcast you
tell her buddy Bob is getting a migraine
I know you're very stressed out by this
it's just one of the reasons why I
appreciate you doing this where was I
we're talking right the mind it and so
there was some paperwork that indicated
that this was from the Zeta Reticuli
star system now yeah now how they
obtained that I haven't I haven't the
slightest idea but it wasn't just from
the Zeta Reticuli star system it was
what they called zr3 so it was a third
planet in that star system so there was
no other information about it other than
that's supposedly where the craft came
from now is that true I don't know I
have no way of verifying that but that
was printed in the same materials that
referenced the reactor now I looked that
stuff up when I went home and Zeta
Reticuli is a binary star two stars that
orbit orbit one another and it's only
visible in the southern hemisphere and
it's about thirty some-odd light-years
away so that's literally all the
information I have about that I don't
know how they found out it came from
there and you also probably have some
suspicions that they give you some
disinformation like you were talking
about before yeah yeah I mean if you
ever decided to talk about this they
added a bunch of nonsense to make
whatever is factual look ridiculous
right or be able to trace it down like
okay this fax came out and you know this
Lazar guy said okay you know came from
Zeta Reticuli so they knew who it was
when red Zeta reticulan we're like what
in the [ __ ] is this well reading all of
the stuff it was what on the [ __ ] is
this you're like why did I sign up for
this no no I would it to me this was
cool this was interesting I said I was
just excited to be out in a secured area
you know in the middle of the desert as
the press is awesome how
I get as in my 20s yeah so you probably
totally geeked out oh yeah it's that
this was this was great I mean I was
excited so I didn't care I've read
through everything and so you read
through all the Zeta particularly thing
but then when you see the actual
starship with the little American flag
sticker on it
well that was was that later or before
that that was before so before so you
see the thing before and you say oh
that's that before it's hard so many
years yeah I can't either way it doesn't
matter the days have fused together it's
so hard to separate what happened in
each visit remember the thought process
when you read that it's from Zeta
Reticuli yeah it it it it didn't hit me
like a ton of bricks or anything is just
like yeah okay [ __ ] I don't know is
worth I don't know I don't I mean
because when I read it I hadn't verified
anything and this was just a bunch of
stuff I was reading and I thought maybe
after this they're just gonna give me a
test and see what I can remember and
write crazy information ever and it
would but like I said when I finally
went in with Barry and had hands-on
experience with what they were talking
about it talked on a completely
different meaning so there's a plate
there's this thing that looks like half
a basketball and when it's on you can't
come anywhere near it you can't touch it
right how is what is gravity about that
like the concept of gravity and most
people's gravity is bringing something
towards it right well I guess you would
say it's anti-gravity its gravity
shifted 180 degrees it's a you know
antigravity and did they have any
understanding about what could possibly
create this effect did they have any
areas where they'd like you to look into
no they well they knew there was a fuel
source in it and they were proficient at
making it work and again my analogy to
something like this is you can drop a
motorcycle off in the wagon train days
and just leave it with the keys parked
outside you know somebody's place
everybody will come around it and
they'll poke and prod and eventually
they'll turn the key get it to start and
become proficient at writing it yeah but
they won't be able to understand what
the hell's going on they won't be able
to make the plastic fender much less
anything else and I think that's exactly
the state we were at we played around
with the parts long enough before I got
there where they could make the reactor
operate take the fuel out and know that
it makes it work how exactly what was
going on in the reactor remained a
mystery at the time I think we made some
progress on what was going on inside but
I don't think anybody really knew
anything they could just watch what was
going on and make note of it
[Applause]